bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue dans cette édition
voici les titres de ce jeudi 17 décembre
la visite de nadia et hier à
chanteloup-les-vignes la ministre
délégué à la ville s'est rendu dans
cette commune dont la mer lancée il ya
quelques semaines un cri d'alarmé pour
les quartiers prioritaires
ce déplacement a été aussi l'occasion de
la signature d'une convention de
rénovation urbaine
ce quartier est sorti de terre il ya 40
ans est l'une des portes d'entrée de
l'agglomération l'hyper centre de saint
quentin en yvelines va connaître une
nouvelle jeunesse
un an après une concertation menée avec
les habitants les premières pistes du
réaménagement été dévoilé hier
et puis à l'horizon 2022 le psg
déménagera de saint germain en laye à
poissy un centre d'entraînement flambant
neuf est en cours de construction
en chiffres 74 hectares 17 terrains de
football et des bâtiments pour héberger
les joueurs le point sur le dossier en
plateau et invité éric roger délégué aux
sports de poissy
mais avant de développer ces titres le
préfet de la région ile de france et est
à trappes cet après midi marc guillaume
est venu durant trois heures sur place
une visite sur le thème de la culture en
compagnie du préfet des yvelines et du
directeur régional des affaires
culturelles
au programme visites de lieux librairie
du millefeuille cinéma du grenier à sel
ou encore le conservatoire de musique la
municipalité a également présenté au
préfet de région ses projets en matière
de culture et nous reviendrons sur cette
venue dans notre journal de la semaine
prochaine avec la crise sanitaire les
maires font aussi face à l'urgence
sociale une centaine d'élus a d'ailleurs
signé un appel pour demander au
gouvernement d'attribuer un milliard
d'euros de son plan de relance pour les
quartiers prioritaires
c'est dans ce contexte que nadia
ministre délégué chargé la ville s'est
rendu dans la commune de champs tous les
lignes 7 et hier mercredi pour
rencontrer associations et élus locaux
sur place nicolas landry le noël de
l'espoir un événement traditionnel à
chanteloup les vignes et c'est en pleine
préparation de ce rendez-vous que la
ministre déléguée chargée de la ville
et s'est rendu dans la commune une
action sociale menée auprès des enfants
de la ville âgés de 2 à 11 ans avec la
distribution de 1429 cadeaux cette année
dans un contexte social particulier
c'est vraiment important de mini genre
d'action c'est ça permet de donner
sourire aux familles aux enfants avec
cette crise sanitaire ça c'est encore
plus paupérisées et là on en arrive à
avoir aussi des difficultés en ce qui
concerne ne serait-ce que l'alimentaire
sans compter tout
les impayés de loyer face à cette
urgence sociale les associations sont en
attente de soutien pour financer des
actions destinées aux familles en
difficulté une situation alarmante aussi
pour le tissu associatif sportif de la
ville
ces 37 2 5% de désinscription cette
année donc on va travailler là en début
d'année avec los andes et associations
sportives mois est en train de créer mon
budget pour absolument qu'on les
accompagne faut absolument qu'on ait
l'assurance que l'état les accompagne
pour rappel catherine arts nous fait
partie des maires qui ont lancé un appel
au président de la république le premier
ministre s'est ensuite engagé à
consacrer 1% du plan de relance au
quartier politique de la ville
objectif financer différentes dispositif
nous avons voulu débloquer un fonds
d'urgence de 20 millions d'euros pour
aider ces associations de grande
proximité comme l'association l'espoir
que nous avons vu tout à l'heure il faut
répondre aussi à la question du chômage
des jeunes dans les quartiers par une
réponse forte sur les développements
économiques sur l'accompagnement à
l'emploi
dans ce contexte la commune poursuit sa
mobilisation dans le cadre de la
rénovation urbaine
la visite de la ministre s'est conclue
avec la signature de la convention en
rue pour le projet destiné au quartier
la noé et vous venez de le voir se
déplaceront est aussi l'occasion d'une
officialisation celle de la deuxième
phase du renouvellement urbain du
quartier de la noé une convention qui
court jusqu'en 2027 a été signé avec l'
agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
un projet global intégrant notamment la
future cité éducative simone veil on
écoute à ce propos la maire de
chanteloup les vignes catherine a renoué
la ministre déléguée chargée de la ville
nadia et au micro nicolas non prix là on
a vu tous les acteurs de terrain que ce
soit là que ce soit de la ville de la
communauté urbaine de l'éducation
nationale autour d'un projet qui a pour
but d'accompagner l'enfant la cité
éducative telle qu'elle vous a été
décrite c'est exactement ça on fait avec
les habitants on peut faire un projet de
territoire est un projet d'avenir
on est parti d'un dispositif de la
politique de la ville pour permettre un
meilleur accompagnement dans le parcours
de l'enfant et nous sommes arrivés à
revoir complètement le quartier à
travers une restructuration de des
établissements scolaires et des
équipements autour autre quartier mais à
saint quentin en yvelines l'hyper centre
va connaître une nouvelle jeunesse le
processus de réaménagement de cette zone
basée à montigny le bretonneux autour de
la gare et du théâtre national notamment
a été lancé depuis un an concertation
avec les habitants travaillent avec un
cabinet d'études pour dresser les
premières orientations de ce
renouvellement est des premières pistes
qui ont été présentés hier mercredi aux
habitants
écoutez cette interview express c'est
une des portes d'entrée avec sagar
quelle est la deuxième gare du 78 on va
aussi les infrastructures routières avec
les sorties d'autoroutes
il accueille aussi une part importante
de notre activité économique universités
le solde commercial régional et aussi la
charnière avec le futur site olympique
du vélodrome et puis à l'est de l'île de
loisirs et on voit bien elle qui
situaient qui fait un peu d'articulation
entre deux facettes importantes de 50
ans adeline c'est à dire le côté très
urbain l'économique avait beaucoup
d'activités le côté le côté nature donc
c'est vraiment un point là effectivement
très important du territoire
c'est un quartier où le livre qui date
des années 80 dont qu'il a il a bien
vécu
et maintenant il a besoin d'être repris
et puis à l'époque où il a été pensé le
parti pris l'aménagement qui avait été
choisie était essentiellement minérale
est privilégiée beaucoup l'automobile
aujourd'hui notre société a évolué on
aspire à a+ des espaces conviviaux des
espaces pour les pouvoirs liés aux pour
passer les bandes ans et puis aussi
évidemment en a plus de végétation de
verdure
donc nous semblait intéressant de
pouvoir est nécessaire de restructurer
aujourd'hui pour lui donner un aspect
qui correspondent mieux aux aspirations
des gens j'ai bloqué par exemple le la
rue du centre on le voit on a mis des
plots qui préfigure un peu déjà ce
qu'ils pouvaient venir comme
aménagements c'est-à-dire imaginé un
dispositif dans lequel on met entre le
le carrefour à 1800 euros bruts avait
fait les puits la place pompidou une
centre eaton qu'ils soient qui occupe
une partie beaucoup plus large de
l'espace de sept voire une liaison entre
eux la sortie de la gare et puis le la
place rapide ou la scène nationale
quittant font de cet espace pour pouvoir
offrir des lieux de convivialité des
lieux où on puisse passer du temps c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on va dans ce
quartier c'est parce qu'on a quelque
chose à y faire mais benoit tu dirais
c'est donc demain ces deux ci devront
conforter l'accueil des gens sur cette
partie parce c'est nécessaire c'est une
centralité comme on le disait donc il
faut permettre aux gens de s'y sentir
bien mais maintenant que ces
orientations ont été présentés la vie
des habitants va être recueilli un ou
plusieurs scénarios de réaménagement
établi objectif faire aboutir les
premiers éléments de cette rénovation
pour les jeux olympiques de 2024
et en parlant des jo c'est officiel la
colline d'elancourt sera bien un site
olympique pour olympique pour les jeux
de 2024 le comité d'organisation des
jeux a dévoilé ce jeudi la carte
définitive de l'événement le lieu saint
quentinois sera la base du vtt épreuve
un temps menacée par les organisateurs
en raison de sa faible audience
télévisée c'est donc bien confirmé le
projet est établi la colline deviendra
un lieu unique en europe pour le vtt
avec une boucle verte de 18 km une piste
olympique mais aussi une piste pour tous
des pistes pour tous
le budget un peu moins de 10 millions
d'euros les yvelines pour rappel qui
seront un lieu important pour ces agios
2024 et golf au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bmx à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin cyclisme au
vélodrome nationale ou encore des
épreuves d'équitation et de pentathlon
moderne à versailles à poissy le paris
saint germain fait construire en ce
moment son futur centre d'entraînement
le club de la capitale va bien rester
dans les yvelines
lui qui est basé aujourd'hui à saint
germain en laye et on en parle avec éric
roger qui est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir
conseiller municipal on vous entend pas
forcément au plateau j'ai demandé juste
à la technique de nous mettre un petit
peu de son en plateau alors je précise
vous êtes conseiller municipal de la
ville de poissy et délégué aux sports
avant de vous poser quelques questions
mickaël miro est avec moi au plateau
bonsoir ça journaliste au sport de la
rédaction de tv 60,18 miquel ce centre
d'entraînement est aujourd'hui en pleine
construction
oui comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces
images le futur centre d'entraînement du
paris saint germain est en train de
prendre forme
on peut commencer à avoir de la
végétation des bâtiments commence
également à sortir de terre une piste
cyclable a en parallèle était construite
à côté bref depuis le lancement des
travaux
le 29 février dernier les équipes
travaillent on écoute jean claude blanc
le directeur général délégué du psg nous
l'avions rencontré en septembre dernier
il ya énormément de machines qui sont
sur le site à poissy pour créer les
trois grandes plateformes sur lequel
nous viendrons construire le centre de
formation pour les jeunes et le centre
d'entraînement pour les professionnels
et donc les construction des bâtiments
eux-mêmes devraient démarrer dans le
courant de l'année 2021 pour s'achever
au début de l'année 2000 23 au total le
futur training center va faire 74
hectares il comprendra 17 terrains de
football dont un couvert il devrait
également y avoir un stade de 5000
places 150 sportifs de haut niveau sont
sur le site quotidiennement
le coût total plus de 200 millions
d'euros le prix d'un joueur comme neymar
un grégory un beau projet pour la ville
qui a dû batailler pour l'obtenir le psg
hésité à quitter saint germain en laye
lieux associés à l'histoire du club de
la capitale et jeu voire était au camp
des loges depuis à 1970 il était même au
camp des loges avant de jouer au parc
des princes 1 grégory qui était alors en
travaux à cette époque dès leur arrivée
en 2011 les qataries ont évoqué ce futur
training center plusieurs sites est
évoqué comme l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines ou encore la commune
de thiverval grignon dans les yvelines
mais les dirigeants ont finalement opté
en 2016 pour cette zone située au bord
de la nationale 13 tout près de
l'autoroute a13 et du centre hospitalier
intercommunal on écoute les réactions
c'est un projet qui valorise le
territoire avant de valoriser la seule
ville de poissy à voir le paris saint
germain sur 75 hectares avec 1000
emplois pendant la durée des travaux 2
millions d'euros de taxes annuelles pour
la communauté urbaine
oui c'est juste c'est juste exceptionnel
faut bien comprendre que une marque
comme le psg
savoir quelle est la implanté dans les
yvelines aura un retentissement
international
c'est une publicité à zéro euro
donc c'est fait quelque chose de
formidable mais à quoi va servir ce
training center il va surtout regrouper
la plupart des sections du paris
saint-germain en un seul et unique lieu
on écoute jean claude blanc il est
important comme dans tous les grands
clubs européens pour noter le paris
saint-germain d'infrastructures qui
permettent de de s'entraîner dans
l'excellence de faire progresser les
jeunes de créer cette mécanique
aspirationnel et donc à terme d'avoir
dans l'équipe de plus en plus de jeunes
qui sont innés qui seront ils né de la
formation du paris saint germain
en tout cas les dirigeants à qatari la
ville de poissy ont déjà commencé à
rentrer le training center dans
l'histoire du psg la nouvelle voie
d'accès s'appellera gris et geek récent
un homme d'affaires qui a participé à la
création du club en 1970 là il en a été
d'ailleurs le premier président il est
décédé en 1996 à l'âge de 76 ans merci
michael pour ces précisions éric roger
la voie d'accès dont parlait
michael va favoriser les mobilités
douces sur 660 mètres voilà sa longueur
il y aura une piste cyclable protégée
115 arbre planté plus de 500 végétaux ça
c'était primordial que cet équipement
certes privée le training center
puissent aussi bénéficier directement à
la ville de poissy officiers caisse même
bonsoir bonsoir nous déjà bien
évidemment on va couper c'était
important qu'ils puissent bénéficier aux
caisses ça va permettre de faire un
certain nombre d'aménagements dans un
prolongement déjà de deux temps plein
par la structure donc en effet très
important que la ville de pau qui
participent et puis voilà on y reviendra
peut-être mais pour pour la ville de
poitiers c'est une vraie fierté d'avoir
le paris saint germain qui portent pas
le coeur à la fête en droit on va en
parler
d'ailleurs il y aussi une dimension
environnementale dans ce projet avec un
potager sur place il ya des arbres qui
vont être aussi planter des poiriers ont
été conservés 1 par le paris saint
germain ce qui aussi permis de
produire un jus de poire du psg ça on
peut pas faire sans aujourd'hui à des
impératifs aussi écologique follet faut
les intégrer dans ce genre de projet il
ya des impacts écologiques
une vraie volonté août signé delà de la
municipalité de la ville de poissy sur
cette partie environnementale et fait un
travail qui a été également avec les
producteurs locaux qui a été fait avec
avec le terroir en définitive il ya vrai
travail de concertation qui a été fait
avec les producteurs qui pouvait être là
avec la municipalité donc voilà le paris
saint germain est très à l'écouté est en
effet élu l'environnement epa pour
important d'ailleurs n'a pas posé une
première pierre de la première arbres
voix pour ancrer le paris saint germain
sur sur cette future terre avec des
travaux qui ont démarré officiellement
on février une centaine de travailleurs
sont actuellement mobilisées sur place
à terme ce sont 100 emplois qui seront
créés
ça va bénéficier directement la
population locale
on en était en tout cas l'objectif c'est
encore une botte un partenariat peu
gagnant gagnant qu'on fait avec le paris
saint germain on a beaucoup d'échangés
avec le pour qu'on soit on réussit à
faire grandir la ville de poitiers mais
également le territoire donc on a très
bon espoir en effet que ça bénéficie au
pic à quai en bonne partie
alors ça un équipement privé je le
disais qui appartiendra bien sûr au
paris saint germain est ce que les clubs
pisciacais pourront tout de même
profiter d'une quelconque manière de cet
équipement on parlait de la possibilité
par exemple pour la s poissy le club de
football qui évolue en nationale 2 4e
niveau national de pouvoir jouer dans un
stade sur un stade de 5000 places qui
sera dans ce training center est-ce que
c'est toujours d'actualité c'est
toujours en discussion chez toujours en
discussions c'est toujours d'actualité
comme vous l'expliqué on est vraiment en
partenariat et remporta gagnant gagnant
que paris saint germain qui est très
ouvert et dans la concertation ce qui
est très appréciable
donc aujourd'hui tout est ouvert donc
voilà c'est des discussions qu'on mène
avec le paris saint germain sur ce sujet
là on parle du foot mais on pourra aller
plus loin sur d'autres sports donc voilà
on travaille en tout cas avec main dans
la main pour pour que possible puissent
en bénéficier pour suivre l'évolution
des travaux il ya un comité de pilotage
croix qui a été créé un comité de
pilotage du projet psg auquel fait
partie la ville de poissy aussi la
communauté urbaine
grand paris seine et oise et et le club
du paris saint germain ça ça permet de
les habitants ça permet de suivre pas à
pas on va dire l'évolution de ce projet
on le rappelle un la fin des travaux la
l'ouverture prévue dans l'année 2022
tout à fait à permettre de padt a pas de
corriger si nécessaire conquis chacun
mais un peu ta pierre à l'édifice qui
est encore une fois un projet de priver
mais mais le paraître par l'état jamais
vraiment dans un esprit de concertation
c'est pour ça qu'on a on a eu des
comités de travail avant l'heure enfin
pendant pendant toute la phase d'étude
ils ont vraiment interroger les
administrés ça c'était important pour la
ville de poissy qu'on puisse avoir un
échange avec les habitants puissent
qu'on a on a un quartier de poissy qui
n'est pas très loin donc c'était
important qui ait cet échange qui soient
créés avec le paris saint germain est
donc ce comité continuer encore une fois
plus on avance plus ça permet d'aligner
qu'on soit vraiment sur la sur la même
longueur d'onde tout au long du projet
et sans revenir sur un vol paris
saint-germain parce que c'est vraiment
une démarche de leur part qui est très
appréciable et que nous nous apprécions
particulièrement en tant qu'élus et aéré
administrés bien évidemment et vous le
disiez à une un travail de concertation
qui a été notamment menées avec les les
pisciacais vous le disiez une grande
fierté pour poissy d'avoir le club du
paris saint germain qui vient dans cette
ville ça représente énormément on
imagine pour pour la ville on va pas
peut-être pas parler du paris poissy on
va rester sur l'identité paris
saint-germain quand même oui tout à fait
paraître chorale le pari pas vers mantes
je vous le confirme
mais voilà mais pourquoi ça fait parler
de poitrine par l'éditeur le président
du conseil départemental de ce club est
bien parler de la renommée
internationale et donc 5 par là bien
évidemment la culture puisque le paris
saint-germain le lieu sera fera partie
du patrimoine affiche à terme définitive
et donc c'est de parler à
l'international de paris saint germain
on parle de quoi si on fait connaître
poissy et ça c'est important et plus
largement d'ailleurs ont fait connaître
le territoire puisque c'est un enjeu
pourquoi j'ai bien évidemment mais un
enjeu de territoire claude important
merci eric roger d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle conseiller municipal de la
ville de poissy délégué aux sports et
merci encore à michael almy doro
journalistes aux sports de la rédaction
de tv 70 on ne manquera pas de vous
tenir informés sur l'évolution de ce
dossier pourquoi pas dans votre émission
sept sports on croise les doigts qui
devrait reprendre normalement en janvier
on l'espère on l'espère dans l'actualité
également à proximité de l'autoroute a10
le parc multimodal de longvilliers
ouvert ses portes ce lieu accueille une
gare routière une aire de covoiturage et
permet de laisser sa voiture sur un
grand parking et ce gratuitement en plus
des partenariats ont été créées
notamment avec la gendarmerie et des
producteurs locaux qui viennent vendre
directement leurs produits sur place
patrick jacques de dixmude et astrid
bergère c'est une première en france le
réseau autoroutier
le parc multimodal de longvilliers est
désormais accessible aux usagers à côté
de la sortie 10 de l'autoroute a10 il
est 1 40 km de paris c'est un lieu
stratégique
il s'agit en fait de mettre à
disposition des parkings des parkings
gratuits qui permettent aux usagers de
l'autoroute et à ceux du territoire qui
habitent aux environs de ce parc et
multimodale de venir sur le parc de
garer leur voiture et ensuite de
profiter d'autres modes de transport qui
peuvent être du covoiturage ou des
transports en bus puisque l'autoroute le
bus ensuite par sur l'autoroute mais
c'est pau n'est pas uniquement un lieu
de transit des partenariats ont été mis
en place
et puis on a en crèche
ce projet dans le territoire en nouant
des partenariats
les partenariats avec la gendarmerie qui
est là et qui va pas qui va passer
régulièrement sur ce pôle et pouvoir
rencontrer les juges et des partenariats
également avec les agriculteurs de la
chambre d'agriculture locale qui vont
vendre ici des produits à destination
des usagers
les producteurs locaux seront sur place
plusieurs fois par semaine
mais même s'ils ne sont pas là les
usagers peuvent récupérer les produits
commandés ou acheter directement sur
place grâce à une banque dans des
casiers fermi c'est une vitrine c'est
une façon de nous faire connaître et de
redonner aux gens de façon à faciliter
le réflexe du local mais on leur
facilitant la tâche est souvent c'est
pas simple il faut aller dans plusieurs
fermes il faut passer beaucoup de temps
là on leur apporte un peu tout ça de
façon groupée
le pôle multimodal propose d'autres
services en plus des sanitaires des
machines à café ou encore un espace de
coworking un espace de détente est
présent avec des livres à disposition
et puis l approche de noël c'est un
produit de luxe particulièrement
apprécié le caviar les français sont
d'ailleurs les troisièmes plus gros
consommateurs au monde dans la petite
commune de mules sont dans les yvelines
une entreprise le conditionne les
produits sont ensuite vendus dans les
plus grands hôtels le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros on peut trouver
de l'or noir dans les yvelines le
comptoir du caviar basé dans la petite
commune de mule 101 pour fonds de
commerce et e d'esturgeons l'atelier qui
emploie une quinzaine de personnes est
installée dans le département depuis 30
ans les ai vus parce que le fondateur de
contente de caviar kia
et son affaire
et est un parisien qui s'est installée
là parce qu'il aimait beaucoup la région
et voilà donc joué notamment
et c'est un environnement tout à fait
exceptionnelle pour pour travailler
avant d'atterrir à 1100 l'objectif de
l'entreprise est de sélectionner les
meilleurs caviars du monde
pour cela les responsables travaille
essentiellement avec des fermes
françaises et d'europe de l'est
le produit est ensuite envoyée dans les
yvelines pour être affinée et
conditionné entre le moment la pêche et
son optimum on va dire de maturité de
goût en général on compte six mois et le
caviar évolué mais il va falloir le
surveiller dans ces boîtes dont on
surveille avec attention les boîtes ont
les retours
éventuellement il faut s'être voilà on
wouts régulièrement afin d'entrer
par cette majorité la société produit
également dans ses 700 m² du tarama fait
à base d'oeufs de cabillaud en ce moment
pour les fêtes la production a doublé
dix mille verrines sont produites chaque
jour ce qu'ils ont fait l'un des
best-sellers de la maison on n'a jamais
vendu aux tempéraments notamment au
moment du confinement parce que c'est un
produit très festif très plaisir une 3
gourmands et les ventes finalement ce
sont
volley donc
donc ça c'est vraiment un produit qui
fonctionne très bien et tout effort
saisonniers il faut après une partie des
produits est ensuite vendue dans cette
boutique parisienne située boulevard
malesherbes une vitrine pour la marque
ouverte depuis 2016
l'objectif ici de démocratiser le caviar
en racontant son histoire
comme vous allez pouvoir retrouver sur
notre mur derrière où on explique ba
trois espèces principales avec lesquels
on travaille comment ça se passe ça se
passe aussi par le fait qu'on propose
aussi systématiquement une dégustation
de nos produits pour que les gens ont
aussi voilà puisse est alors
l'explication mais aussi l'expérience en
même temps le caviar de la marque se
retrouve également dans les épiceries
fines dans les grands hôtels et
restaurants français et à l'étranger si
vous voulez tester le premier prix est à
23 euros les 20 g
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité demain vendredi vous
retrouverez et honore sinoquet pour une
nouvelle édition et dans un instant sur
tv 78 ne manquez pas un nouveau numéro
de si on rentrait c'est l'émission qui
vous occupe à domicile c'était cas
c'était le cas pendant le confinement et
on continue pendant cette période de
couvre feu
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]